tu penses que je suis dans la même plus
classe de chirel sur l aile et où seules
baisses de la journée les enfants les
cherry et donc on a on a on a fait appel
en fait aux mini chroniqueur nous avons
avec nos minimes mathieu faut dix mois
pour lui
bonjour bonjour bonjour tu t'appelles
matthieu delormeau d'accord très bien
c'est qui ton chroniqueurs préférés à
part toi jean luc jean luc lemoine tu as
bien jean-luc lemoine qu'on va voir dans
un instant car pussy lanarvily capsule
avec à vous
comment cela va capucine doigts ça va
bien ma chérie tu es en forme et avec le
fils de qui en ce moment
non t'as pas de fiancé est influencée
j'ai pas tu sais pas cette écoute avec
la fin et après la fin en plaine
c'est la première fois en faisant sa
première fois que tu fais là dessus
comme 1 me maman m'a dit que c'était toi
qui étais là ouais et va suivre où j'ai
dit mais je connais le vix yamini agathe
kate avait cumulé à bientôt
et la ligne à gâteau poids les fameuses
comment ça va agathe moins ça va tu es
content d'être là oui pas fiancés temps
quelle classe non sans quelques classes
pépite bcp bcp coin vip et bi d'été dans
mes temps quelle classe vraiment c'est
pas seulement passer la sepnb et au
savon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pan cpa non cpb énervé en fait on pas
quand on compare avec les chiens aboient
je m'appelle si la noix
c'est vraiment ma chérie eliane d'hydra
mais nick a pu l atout de capucine la la
thierry mombo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa voiture et oui comme en tant que
classe toi un cd vcd comme d'habitude
tout autant je suis dit
[Applaudissements]
je l'avais bien dit qui tu l'appelles
qui tire tout haut
[Musique]
je vote
est-ce que tu as une blague eh oui vas-y
mon fond de moi ça dans mes 14 juillet
le fonds de brosses à dents le 14
juillet chez ba ba adjoint feu
dentifrice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas pareil
on a avec nous me gilles verdez
applaudissements bon
[Applaudissements]
on a vendu sa bien je te plaît les
chiffres commencent à l'origine très
bien alors tu es content d'être là oui
tu as quel âge toit faute à thé tout
calme toi mon chéri 1 oui auquel cas ce
fait pcp tu travailles bien cpb fait des
ccp ses doigts ouais et agathe et au
agathe la gamme minis agathe il ya 70
ans épatant cpcp baby lui lancer pc non
à speedy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors mon chéri tu vas tu travailles à
l'école tu as une fiancée pas
d'amoureuse nom est content d'être là
oui tu connais gilles verdez oui comment
il est en fait je connais pas mis musab
allemand
comment sera mue l'isabelle ça va très
bien vous avez quel âge 15 ans quinze
ans ça va vous êtes en classe en
troisième troisième c'est votre vrai
coiffure tout ça non pas d'accord en
tout cas ça vous va très bien et laissez
les appels morini-bosc un petit peu ça
là où tu travailles bien toi ouais ça va
tu es content d'être avec nous oui tu
connais isabelle multiples moyens pas de
paille ouf
ouais non c'est vrai qu'ils que tu
connais mieux de l'équipe
qu'est ce que tu préfères toi tu devrais
pas de faire un petit bisou oui
[Musique]
il est
on a mieux le racket avec nous avec
c'est vrai
il est là
comment ça va miner nos biens est
content d'être là oui ça va tu aimes
bien la télé ouais tu regardes quoi la
télé dessin animé ouais t'as quel âge
c'est un certain temps de classe ah oui
je sais pas
c'est pas tes pensées plus belle il
paraît gaucher comme gerald en fait
comme têtue et enfin je pense que si
dans la même plus classe de chirel sur l
aile et houssen gbagbo
je m'appelle parce que ce qui se passe à
gaz pour t'énerver très prisé makoun ou
convoi à quelque un autre mois toute
façon il ya beaucoup d'amour ou noah
c'est vrai moi c'est vrai que moi dans
mon et les vernis à illizi non pas du
zamalek est amoureuse tu as beaucoup
d'amoureux tu as beaucoup d'amoureux oui
toi tous les garçons sont amoureux de
toi c'était très serré et est très belle
et toi tu es amoureuse d'un garçon
ah oui quand il s'appelle i go go et
alors il fait du piano comme ma soeur
enfin elle fait de l'art et alors miss
japon a besoin de nous parler mais je
tiens par allaoui bazile la fatigue aux
nerfs de rigolos et des temps en temps
il est beau il est beau
oui et en plus ce magasin agricole doit
sortir avec lui
nantes est trop petit mais non bah si
elle en a envie mais non ne peut pas
taxer tôt
qui pense qu'elle doit sortir avec ugo
monye mathieu quoi tu auras gars tu
penses mais moi pourquoi parce qu en
fait avec très joli et puis victoire
mais comment sa famille ses droits alors
5e et améliorera d'awacs nettoie bien
que lui aussi il ya sept ans comme moi
très bien d'un voyage web on va voir
mais c'est trop petit c'est trop petit
pour moi c'est trop petit et on a enfin
jeux minis jean luc est avec nous
[Musique]
ça va ça va mal et les jambes bien bas
toi là tu t'appelles tu me lis j'entends
exactement ça va bien tu très élégant
merci je vais très beau si vraiment tu
as quel âge de 12 ans 12 ans top class 6
5e 5e à 3 était encore en sixième
abbas était content tu connais jean luc
lemoine jean tu ne connais pas non tu
vas découvrir
d'accord vous l'a jamais vu si tu as
déjà vu toi tu connais n'aura n'ont même
pas et en plus de ça qui a une traîne
sur le sol quelques mois sont plus agité
que les oui
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu viens retirer franchement
les babines c'est comment tu t'appelles
ça elle enfin ça va tu as quel âge
navré il est pas bon raphaël agathe
agathe tu te calmes il est pas beau
raphaël il est beau mais c'est 6
d'accord vit très bien d'accord relatif
on se calme et les saucisses les chéris
d'accord les merguez l'accord les
saucisses non ok